welcome to the seafarm massey talks la
conference massey see far
so my name is natalie de rosier i'm the
principal of massey college and it's my
great pleasure to welcome you here i
want to say that massey college is built
on indigenous lands the lands of the
yeon wenda the seneca and the
mississaugas of the credit i want to
acknowledge our duty of stewardship
toward this land which is the treaty
land of the mississaugas of the credit
and our great privilege
to continue to do and reflect on the
future of vaccine which is what we're
going to discuss today without further
ado we have lots to discuss today so let
me pass the microphone to uh
the president of cfar alan bernstein one
of canada's foremost uh
uh scientist uh recipient of so many
honors and a great leader in
framing and helping us cope with the the
big questions of our of our time uh alan
it's such a pleasure to continue to do
uh partnership between massey and sifar
and thank you for your intellectual
leadership
thank you very much natalie for that uh
very kind introduction and it's nice to
see you virtually
uh at this meeting uh good afternoon
everyone and uh welcome to the cfar
massey talks uh cfar is very pleased yet
again to partner with messi on this
annual series of conversations at the
nexus of science and society it's
especially a pleasure for me to co-host
this year's event with nasa lee who is
having so much impact
she's in her third year
as the new principal i'll still say new
principal of messi she's just doing
such a fabulous job we're sort of a
mutual admiration society here in
athlete
this annual lecture series
started in 2015
and highlights not only a distinguished
senior scientist in this case derrick
rossi who i'll say something about in a
moment but also some of the amazing
junior fellows
at massey that gives massey the the
energy that it has
previous lectures have spanned issues
such as the ai revolution unsolved
mysteries of the galaxy
and how social relationships affect our
health
all of our past talks are available on
cfar's youtube channel and today's event
will also be posted there in about a
week
this afternoon's talk could not be more
timely
mrna vaccines as everybody knows have
played i think it's fair to say the
central role in the fight against covet
19
saving i think millions of lives over
the past year alone this technology has
the potential to revolutionize how we
treat other diseases including diseases
serious diseases like cancer
going forward
and we'll say more about that of course
in a moment first i'd like to also
introduce our moderator wendy lung
whencey is a
massey journalism fellow she's a
toronto-based health reporter for the
globe and mail and is part of a team of
journalists currently covering the coven
19 pandemic prior to joining the globe
she worked at the prague post the
vancouver son of cambodia daily and
thompson writers
and joining me in this discussion is
derek rossi
derek is a a serial
biotech entrepreneur
a great stem cell scientist
his efforts in the development of
cutting-edge technologies and novel
therapeutic strategies are at the very
forefront of both regenerative medicine
and biotechnology
his development of
mrna reprogramming was named by time
magazine as one of the top 10 medical
breakthroughs of 2010.
that same year derrick leveraged that
technology to found moderna a company
developing modified mrna therapeutics
and whose covet vaccine is being
deployed
around the world
derek and i share a special history
as he was one of my graduate students
i guess in the last century derek
uh so welcome wednesday and derrick
i'd also like to welcome our massey
junior fellows who will join our
discussions later on nicholas
barbarovitz zavani maskaran
before we begin i would like to take
this opportunity to again thank monty
college our partners in this annual
sephar massey talk
see far like massey is a strong believer
in the power of diversity
interdisciplinary communities of inquiry
of excellence and of young people we
also believe in sharing new knowledge
that we gain from science with everybody
the cfar massey talks are a great
example of exactly the kind of
initiative that helps bring research to
a wide audience into the forefront
now to get this started i'll pass the
virtual microphone to unc and i hope
everybody enjoys this this hour's talk
wency
thank you so much for that introduction
ellen and thank you for having me here
today um let's talk vaccines
my first question is for derek um so as
as ellen mentioned you've been involved
in the research that led to the creation
of mrna uh vaccines for more than a
decade so i'm wondering pre-precovid
what were you and other scientists
trying to do with an mrna vaccine
technology
well i i will um
tell you what we were doing in the lab
and it was something totally unrelated
to vaccines or or for that matter mrna
therapeutics we were working on a and
this is often the way in science you're
working on something or you think you're
working on something but in fact you're
working on something
else so we were working on a problem
related to stem cell biology
and
we decided to
use
mrna as a strategy to get to the end
that we were trying to get to in stem
cell biology
and it totally didn't work it was a you
know a
a complete and utter a disaster we
killed essentially all the cells in the
dish
and by the way i'll just say that mrna
was discovered to be the intermediate
between dna
and protein
protein synthesis proteins of the worker
bees of the cells dna contains the code
but mrna is this necessary and obligate
intermediate molecule that was that
discovery was made in in 1961
yet in the intervening decades
although
many tried many failed using mrna to
express
proteins of interest to to biologists
and similarly we followed in that path
so that could have been the end of the
story but we persevered we found a
workaround we we discovered some uh
forgotten work uh by some uh uh
important researchers at the university
of uh pennsylvania uh captain kirico and
drew weissman who by the way i'll
predict will win the nobel prize
but their work had sort of been
published and was sort of forgotten
about and we found it uh and built upon
it uh and discovered through some you
know development that we could use this
molecule to express any protein we
desired
both in the dish and then in animals uh
and that was what led me to found
moderna in 2010
right okay and and and so how did how
did how did this kind of um
how did how did it become um applied to
to covert 19
well interestingly when i um started the
company the first uh the first investor
that i had was one of my colleagues at
harvard a guy named tim springer
and the very first meeting we had to
talk about it we talked about vaccines
and
we we talked about it
mostly in the setting of a company that
was already trying to develop mrna
vaccines a german company called curvac
and i
so tim said to me derek what about
cureback they're ready to do in vaccines
and i said yeah but it's not gonna work
because
they're not doing the right
modifications to the mrna and sure
enough surface recently had their cova
trial results come out and indeed it
didn't work so these modifications were
necessary
so i got a little i took a tangent
though so
remind me what your actual question was
mine see i'm sorry oh yeah yeah sorry so
so so the the groundwork that you had
with with this tech technology with um
mrna um
modification modified mrna uh technology
like how how did that kind of um where
did that leap come from to to apply that
to oh vaccines thank you yeah yeah
sorry it's two not enough cup cups of
coffee yet today um so as i said we
talked about it in 2010
but and quite frankly i didn't want to
work on vaccines because it was a
therapeutic paradigm for which there was
already really great solutions i mean
vaccines have been in in the
the
uh human
involved in human health since 15th
century china in a very big well way
since the uh 18th century
and there are many ways to make vaccines
that work rather what i wanted to do was
work on developing medicines for which
there was no
treatment at all and there's literally
thousands of genetic diseases for which
there isn't a
an application right now or a
therapeutic strategy to tackle so i
really wanted to to tackle uh genetic
disease there's 6 000 genetic diseases
not including cancer
mrna is a perfect solution for that so
when the company first started that is
what we were focused on
at about five or six years in though we
turned attention to vaccines because
quite frankly it's um
it's got the lowest
um technical hurdle you could imagine
when you're bringing a new medicine to
patients a new therapeutic paradigm you
shouldn't go after you know try to jump
over really really high hurdles you
should jump over the smallest hurdles
possible
to you know demonstrate that your
technology works and is safe and
applicable to humans so vaccines present
a perfect opportunity for that so
honestly that is how moderna got into
the vaccine
business as kind of a hey this is an
easy first application a really technic
the technical hurdle being the smallest
and
then the pandemic hit of course they had
already developed multiple different
vaccines and run them through clinical
trials at the fda and this was actually
part of the story that people don't know
it's not the first time that that mrna
was applied to vaccines was uh stars
cove 2 in copen 19. now there was trials
run on zika and
rare and deadly forms of influenza and
uh settlement virus and others so that
this experience was gained
uh that it was safe
uh there was a dose range that we knew
would would likely work
and um moreover that when you immunize
somebody against a pathogen they hadn't
seen before you could really uh robustly
stimulate the immune system to
uh generate antibodies and and and
other immune cells that would uh uh
be uh
yeah the the foundation for a successful
uh vaccine
right okay so so you so you mentioned
these other the these other types of um
viruses
that that um this technology was was
um
developed to be applied to so so beyond
beyond um the stars cov2virus what what
um are mrna vaccines and therapeutics
are in the works right now like what's
what's in the pipeline okay well well
the the pipeline is
uh huge and it's getting larger by the
day because literally you know mrna new
mrna companies are springing up like
mushrooms around the planet uh and all
of large pharma is going all in with
with mrna so just for the companies that
that have been in it for a while for
example modern and you know bion tech
and even curavax uh you know there's
there's vex
i would argue that the entire vaccine
industry is going to be mrna based uh
within five years
you know influenza a yearly influence of
vaccine is coming you know zika
vaccine hiv
epstein borovirus
nipah virus and we really hope that
nipah doesn't really jump into humans
because it's really deadly
so the the list of uh clinical programs
that are already in the clinic and or
close to the clinic is long for vaccines
uh it's equally long for therapeutics um
you know the
when you have the ability to use mrna to
express a protein proteins are set
involved in essentially every aspect of
our biology and
uh every aspect of our
pathophysiology in the setting of
disease so there's so many you know the
but one of the challenges we had with
madura in the early days is what to work
on first because we could work on
literally thousands of applications so
i'm really excited by the fact that that
you know this
massive global spotlight has been shown
on this technology it's proven itself to
be
really robust uh and um
now there's this massive influx of of
resource uh mobilized both people brain
brain power
and a
financial resource so i i really see
that you know that
the future
for mrna vaccines is clear
i think the whole industry is going
vaccines but i would say mrna
therapeutics are pretty close to being a
reality as well so we will see that over
the next
few years uh and decades to come
right
on on this issue of the the
the international scientific
collaboration like um
ellen maybe you can talk about
what has that that role the role been in
terms of the international collaboration
in creating um increasing mrna vaccines
so quickly for covet 19.
well you know it's interesting um
the the sequence of the virus was was
first developed by
scientists in china in late december
early january 2020
and they
put that sequence on the web
and it was moderna who i think first
captured that sequence off the web it
was public but got the sequence off the
web and within about four or five days
had really developed a vaccine that
we're all using now anybody's got the
maternal vaccine was the one that was
made four or five days after
uh back in jan early january 2020 uh so
that that the whole scientific effort
really turned on global scientific
collaboration starting with i think
really an amazing uh gesture by
scientists in china
so we shouldn't forget that that was
absolutely key and of course the the
vagina vaccine took another nine months
to actually test in humans to make sure
it was safe and effective but but the
the actual vaccine was made within days
and that's the power of the mrna
vaccines
is that they're a plug and play kind of
thing you can
synthetically
in the lab
you don't have to grow anything in cells
like you do with the viral vector
vaccines you don't have all the protein
production challenges you have with
protein subunit vaccines that the big
companies like sanofi and now novavex
are having with the protein supplements
against covert so
that global collaboration has been key i
think the other aspect of all this of
course is
that the the scientific community
globally has been sharing information
quickly and openly for the last almost
two years now around this back around
this pandemic
both vaccine development but also the
epidemiology the modeling
all aspects of drug development all
aspects of this so it's been i think one
of the great lessons
um for the world and certainly for the
scientific community but and for our
political leaders has been how important
this global collaboration is
because the end of the day this is not a
canadian problem or an american problem
it's a global problem and so uh you know
if we don't if we don't address this
pandemic everywhere
we're not
having dealt with the pandemic so we
need to be working together on this
both from the scientific point of view
the the politics point of view
making vaccines delivering vaccines
around the world etc etc etc and i think
so that
that initial act of sharing that
information the sequence information of
the virus
uh really is what the whole thing has
turned on i think the other thing is
you know
unlike every previous pandemic that's
happened
on this planet including the sars one
which didn't turn into a pandemic
luckily because it's a very lethal virus
it sort of burned itself out pretty
quickly but um we've had this is a
pandemic characterized by science
if you think about
the molecular surveillance to detect all
these variants
and the pcr reaction
to see who's got the virus
and now the mrna vaccines of course
this is all new
technology that was not available back
in 2002 we couldn't have done any of
this in 2002. this was very you know
sequencing was around but it was very
primitive so all of this comes out of
global scientific collaboration um that
won a number of nobel prizes derek
mentioned maybe a nobel prize in the
future or near future hopefully for the
group in philadelphia perhaps other
people
but the um
the pcr reaction that uh is a node was
one nobel prize
as did uh dna sequencing so i think
we're really seeing uh a scientifically
driven control of these pathogens based
on global collaboration it's really
quite remarkable i'll just i'll just
jump into that one more thing to say
that luckily it was science that was the
industry that was
relied upon to to to meet this challenge
because
science actually knows no borders
that's the way science works we we but
you know scientists are you know very
you know we publish our work in
international journals we collaborate
internationally is what science does so
science knows no borders so luckily it
felt to science to uh you know meet this
challenge had it you know fell to i
don't know some other industry you know
maybe the
let's say the political
political class
if they
you know imagined that somehow they
could have solved this problem that
would have been a bigger problem because
that sort of global collaboration isn't
set up so i think if science was poised
and but alan's right you know many
things needed to be uh
discovered and at the ready to to
respond so quickly and and so the timing
was right uh in terms of the
technologies but certainly science
responded as science does i think so
i think it's a great moment for science
quite frankly
okay
let me get back to the the global uh
efforts in in a moment but um i wanted
to to ask
derek
in terms of of um these other other
types of applications for the mrna
vaccines
how how do mri a vaccines work for say
cancer compared to stars cov2
yeah so um so
actually there's there's three sort of
lines that one can approach with with
cancer vaccines
so the first is that
many cancers
express
new found pro new proteins that are
specific to cancer cells they're called
neoantigens so cancers tend to be very
mutagenic
it's a large part of driving cancer as a
mutagenic phenotype with new uh
combinations of proteins translocations
and point mutations arising so these are
called neoantigens
so um
you could imagine targeting uh making a
vaccine against neo uh common
neoantigens so for example a really good
example of that is a gene called k-ras
so k-ras is involved in
you know more than 25 of all human
cancers and very specific mutations
happen in the k-ras gene so it drives
you know 40 of colorectal cancers
cancers 85 of pancreatic cancers 30 of
lung cancers it's a lot of cancer
so uh k ras with these particular
mutations you can immunize somebody
prior
to so be a prophylactic vaccine such
that
should their body generate a k-rask
mutation they might already have uh
protection in place and their clinical
programs are ongoing for that
another way that you could imagine a
cancer vaccine is um
somebody already has cancer and you
could sequence their neo antigens again
using you know really pretty much
everybody that gets cancer in in a
and visits a major hospital has their
their their tumors sequenced so you know
what's the underlying molecular drivers
and what neo antigens are present and so
you could actually develop and mrna is
so fast you know alan mentioned it a
little while ago
you could very quickly generate you know
mrnas for neo antigens for somebody
who's come in and is presenting a tumor
so that would be a sort of a very
personalized cancer vaccine and these
studies are also in the clinic and
ongoing
and then the final area i think
because i think cancer is really the
frontier that we're going to next really
see a major impact from the mrna
technology and the one that i
particularly like is intra-tumor
delivery of mrnas so you you know you
can scan somebody's body you can see
where their tumors are and most of the
time you can get some sort of a needle
in there
into the tumor
generally speaking uh and you could now
have the tumor deliver some mrna to
express
uh uh proteins that for example call in
the immune system you know bring in the
immune system so you know they're
programs for il-12 for example is in
phase uh two at moderna again it's this
uh cytokine that that um
regulates a couple of immune cells
natural killer cells and cytotoxic t
cells and you know you're still putting
this right into the center and by the
way tumors normally have very good
mechanisms for shutting out immune
infiltration so this is a way to combat
that and i i'm really encouraged by that
approach so there's there's multiple
different ways to approach cancer with
with mrna and i really think i would i
would predict that
next to vaccines
uh application and tumors will will be
and tumor biology will be a big frontier
and we'll see some great successes in
that uh forthcoming but that is a
forward-looking statement by the way
okay wow well um ellen i know for for
you hiv is a as a particular interest
how um
how how how might
scientists approach creating an mrna
vaccine for something as complicated as
hiv
well again you know it's um
it's
as derek was talking about her his early
days in this area science does not go in
a straight line so one of the pioneers
in this area that made the vaccines
possible that that the the covet 19
vaccines it's a guy called barney graham
and barney was working on a number of
different viruses including hiv
uh and discovered that if you wanted to
take that the equivalent of the spike
protein for hiv you needed to sort of
lock it into a certain shape so that the
body with the immune system in your body
would actually see it make an immune
response so he and a postdoc figured out
how to do that for other viruses
and that's been applied now
to covet
so
as
derek's been saying for all these other
viruses and for therapeutic vaccines
now of course we're thinking about
making vaccines against hiv
the challenge with hiv is that the
variants that we're so worried about
with covid which come up you know once
every three or four months there's a new
variant with hiv it's you know one a day
it's a very mutable virus and so new
viruses are coming up all the time so
the one issue would be is it possible
just as derek was talking about with a
personalized vaccine development for
cancer could you make personalized
vaccines
for a particular variant of hiv that
predominates in a region and then make a
different one every time it changes so
you're always one step ahead hopefully
of where hiv is going and so you're
constantly
re-synthesizing this plug-and-play
technology to kind of catch up with the
virus or hopefully be one step ahead of
it
so that that's there's a lot of work
going on in that area with the mrna
vaccine technology so um i think that
that
this is very this technology is
perfectly applicable
to this to hiv and to other situations
where you really got to keep
re-engineering the vaccine
and we should remember that delta is
about the fourth or fifth generation of
variants yet the vaccine that is so
effective against delta
was actually the original vaccine that
was made against the wuhan strain that
came out of wuhan in the first place
i i was asked the other day by a
reporter
what happens if that no that actually no
longer works what happens if the the new
variant well it'd be so easy to
re-engineer
uh the vaccine to deal with that new
variant
indeed i'm sure modern and i'm sure
pfizer et cetera have done all that and
well i know they have so um
that's what we have to do with with hiv
the other thing i would say wednesday is
we shouldn't forget that we're still in
sort of the model t stage
of mrna technology
this is early early early days if you
look at other scientific technologies
whether it's dna sequencing pcr reaction
you name it
they change so quickly so to take dna
sequencing which every lab is doing as
derek said if you have cancer and we're
sequencing all these viruses now the
cova 19 doing genomic surveillance
to actually detect the delta variant in
our populations
the cost of doing that sequencing and
the efficiency of doing it has gone down
over 10 million fold over about 20 years
that's because they're whole new
technologies so i think we can safely
predict
that the mrna vaccine mrna vaccine
technology
is not going to stay the same
it's going to get better
and we're going to go from model of t's
to chevy's to bmws pretty quickly um and
and and maybe tesla's so uh you know i
think i think it's going to be
that'll open up because technology is
always rate limiting that's going to
open up whole new applications
that are truly
impossible for us
at the moment
okay yeah
alan i remember sorry wendy i remember
doing some of the early model t version
dna sequencing in your lab back in the
1980s uh and it was you know labor
intensive and slow
and and so exactly to your point um but
but it's a good southern blots when
you're in the lab a lot i i did a lot of
southern blots indeed uh so
um
but i think you're exactly right
actually you know we're it's in its
infancy now and and as i said you know
now there's so much money and resource
and people being mobilized to work on mr
you know next-gen mrna technology and
applications that can only do exactly as
you said which is you know
lead to innovation in this space so
that's going to happen it's a really
it's an important point
so i guess like on on the road to
getting there to that that bmw stage
what sort of um
what sort of drawbacks or or think
cautions do you think
we need to take
well so the the biggest thing
um and i've said this for a really long
time is delivery delivery delivery so
mrna is a macro molecule
it's very very large
um
it
relat
relative to you know a small molecule
like an aspirin or something like that
which is tiny by comparison
um
so get it and and it can't do anything
unless it gets through the cell membrane
into the cytoplasm and goes to the
ribosome which is the protein production
organelle and you know to have its code
red to turn into a a
a protein so delivery
i've been saying
it was always going to be the challenge
well this is where you know lipid nano
particles have met the challenge already
partially for this so everybody's heard
of lip and nano particles now they're
these little sort of fat droplets that
do two things they protect the you know
they they protect the mrna
uh in this you know inner sphere
going into the into the body which by
the way we express a lot of molecules
whose job is to specifically degrade rna
rnases so it protects but it also
facilitates uptake into cells uh and
allowing the mrna to be delivered
uh and lipid nanoparticle technology is
a community
development
that was a canadian development but we
have absolutely yeah yeah it's got a
long long history and
and and it's it's and each generation of
lip banana particles is getting better
and better and better and less and less
sort of you know have side effects
because early generations had side
effects and were quite toxic
uh i think the thing that that i'm
really looking forward to and i know
it's happening already uh in another
company i found it intellio therapeutics
one of these christopher companies uh is
decorating the lnp with sort of address
tags
to send it to particular cell types and
tissue types uh because you know when
we're injecting into our arm here it's a
non-specific uh delivery it's just going
into our arms so it's getting into our
muscle
our dendritic resident dendritic cells
and resident
immune cells but that's you know pretty
relatively non-specific i think it's
going to get really exciting when we can
put mrna into an lmp or another type of
delivery vehicle put a very specific
address tag on it and get it to go right
to a particular cell type or tissue type
in the body i think that's that's so i
would argue that that's still a
limitation i think your question was
what are the limitations right now
that's certainly a limitation
it's also
you know a big limitation honestly with
this current pandemic is manufacturing i
mean
you know there was not uh the capacity
the manufacturing infrastructure to
produce many billions of doses you know
in the few weeks that we wish that we
could have produced many billions of
doses
to deploy around the world so uh that is
also changing i mean moderna had a gmp
grade uh manufacturing facility built
already very boldly in 2018 it's about
20 minutes north of me here in norwood
mass but now uh facilities are are
popping up around the planet again so
and canada has uh
is on board with doing a an mrna
facility africa both pfizer and modern
are going to africa which i think is
amazing it'll be all around the planet
so i think one of the uh the next time
and there will be a next time that a
pandemic comes
and this technology is able to address
it we'll be able to do it on an even
faster timeline because of this
manufacturing bottleneck which we have
found ourselves in this past year
so wednesday
i would say when derek said delivery i
was going to agree with him he went a
different direction with the word
delivery
um i i think that
you know it's one thing to make vaccines
but you have to vaccinate people
and so you have to deliver them into
those arms uh and that involves
manufacturing as derek said it also
involves
uh dollars because you have to need the
money to actually
make these things um and so going back
to your question about global
collaboration against where uh wealthy
countries have a long way to go
to really provide the resources
financial resources and and
manufacturing
resources for africa
for the developing world and for those
countries everywhere that can't afford
to do it because if we've learned from
delta if nothing else if the virus is
anywhere it's everywhere it you know
we're fooling ourselves that we think if
we get rid of the virus you know here in
ontario we've eliminated the pandemic
we know that's not true
it's just we
have proof of that the delta move from
india to ontario in in about a week
sars one moved from hong kong to canada
in about three days we all travel around
the world you know et cetera et cetera
so
delivery is a key issue and of course
vaccine hesitancy is another one uh
because again you have to get the
vaccine into arms it's not enough to do
the science manufacture it and
distribute it and pay the money you need
to get people to to line up and get in
their arms and i think that requires a
lot of political leadership i think we
saw that very clearly uh throughout this
pandemic in different countries
and it requires dealing with this
misinformation issue
uh that's so rife on the web
and all of us you know have got friends
relatives who say well but i heard that
the vaccines uh you know prevent you
from getting pregnant i want to get
pregnant well you know they see they'll
say one crazy message so it really
those are major issues which i never
would have predicted but it have turned
out to be major issues in terms of
actually dealing with the pandemic and
now
the only people really who are getting
serious disease from covet in north
america are people who are not fully
vaccinated
uh and it's a shame you know they're
getting really seriously ill or dying or
getting long covered
um and and nobody you know you don't
want that uh because they're they're
really getting full of misinformation
and of course people in africa are not
even getting that opportunity to get
vaccinated so i think delivery is a big
issue
so in terms of this misinformation and
vaccine hesitation
what do you think needs to happen to
um
you know in terms of of all these other
applications for mrna technologies what
needs to happen to to to sort of
um
get the get the public on on board with
with yeah actually well well well it you
know starts education i mean honestly
it's interesting when when the pandemic
first hit and you know mrna was
mentioned in the press as a potential
application it's it amazed me i guess
that you know people didn't actually
know what mrna was you know the average
person in a town people have heard of
dna they know it contains the code
people have heard of proteins although
they mostly think it's something that
they eat with their steak or in their
but they're the [ __ ] you know the the
real busy worker bees but people hadn't
known about mrna so i spent about last
year and a half two years
basically giving every webinar i
possibly could anybody that asked sort
of educating about what mrna is and what
vaccines are we've seen a lot of that so
so education is really really the way
um
you know people have to realize that
scientists are actually the most
skeptical people on planet earth
when when scientists make a discovery
uh there's nobody who wants to challenge
that discovery more than the person
who's made the discovery so you make a
discovery in science and then you spend
two years throwing rocks at your own
discovery doing everything possible to
to show that somehow you've
misinterpreted the result or so derek
let me let me jump in here
i gave the very first massey see far
talk
and it was about the scientific process
and its title was doubt everything
yeah exactly throw rocks you know
scientists throw rocks at their own data
and by the way their peers sure do that
when they when they go to publish their
peer-reviewed papers
so uh
facebook is not the domain of science
and the internet is not the domain of
science and i i say it all the time and
i say it now i take the opportunity the
internet is a liar there's a lot of
great stuff out on the internet but
there's a lot of nonsense and certainly
social media there's probably more
nonsense than great stuff so we have to
educate the public that that really the
domain of science is
in scientific journals and that science
is real and that science is not in
collusion with governments to
uh you know
enact you you you can't believe some of
the emails i get from people i mean just
they they're they they boggle my mind
um so it's a big deal and some countries
and some governments do it better than
others so for example i was just in
spain the end of last week beginning of
uh
over the weekend in a town called oviedo
in the north of spain where you know
myself along with a few of the other
really key people involved in the
vaccine were being celebrated by an
award ceremony and the entire town
250 000 people was engaged
and
you know they've been doing research
they had the the children doing uh i saw
they had a project 2 000 school kids
did pictures on what the job of the
scientist is and what we had been doing
to develop this vaccine you know so it
engages the school-age kill children
then we had a forum with high school
kids we had an open public discourse and
when you actually talk to scientists
real scientists uh you find out oh what
do you know they're they're they're real
people they're not in collusion they
seem to be passionate about what they do
and my goodness they're pretty darn
skeptical in the end so you know science
is real and uh we've it's it's i i was
shocked at how science could become sort
of a political level particularly i live
in the us
i'm canadian but i live in the us
uh and it's shocked me how that how how
that has happened here maybe it
shouldn't be shocking but uh it's it's
problem it's a real problem and and we
need to educate
educate from the ground up small
children all the way through that
science is real
right okay
um
one one just last question and and we'll
make it quick before i start introducing
the massey fellows but um i i wondered
you know on the on the subject of
delivery and and and and
with with the idea of a global
collaboration in making these these
technologies what are your thoughts on
sharing those help protect the the
recipes for those technologies to to
so that people around the world can
access them well well that's a good
question um
so i would argue
that um
it and i agree with alan i mean we have
to vaccinate the planet that that's
that's clear the the the
the bottleneck is not that the recipe
isn't shared with around the planet the
bottleneck is manufacturing and the
expertise didn't manual prep so that's
the bottleneck
and i would argue that intellectual
property is really really important for
the science for science to continue to
innovate and continue to develop
key medicines if you take away inter
intellectual property protection you are
going to have less private sector
investment
in in technologies that one day could
deliver the answer so i think
i'll jump in here and then i think we
should move on but i think you can
you can square the circle in other words
i think in this in a case of a global
pandemic
i think it is possible to respect you
know intellectual property
rights and issues
while sharing the formula as it were and
actually assisting with the production
during the period of a pandemic so that
there's there's a the the ip's protected
but we also protect the world because
the end of the day
it's
maybe not in the case of but well maduro
used public funds as well but there was
public funds considerable public funds
used to develop these vaccines so i
think we need to kind of figure out a
way to both respect ip
as well as share the formula and get it
i would i would agree with that so i
didn't i didn't mean to suggest
otherwise just to say though that ip is
such an important uh pillar
of biotechnology and innovation so you
really can't just you just can't get rid
of it because you're going to have a
much bigger problem in the future if you
do that so i agree there's there's a way
to square the circle and do both but
that's not the challenge here the
challenge is manufacturing is
manufacturing yeah i agree with
manufacturing we should move on to hear
all these great jobs let me uh let me
give the the fellows a chance to ask
some questions
um so let me first introduce uh nicholas
robovitz
he is
an md non-resident junior fellow and he
nick is a medical student and health
researcher with interest in emergency
medicine
public health and research methods
and he's the research lead at zero
tracker which is a public website that
tracks and analyzes covert 19 prevalence
globally
and we also have um shivani
bayiskarin
savani is a phd candidate in
environmental chemistry at the
university of toronto and in addition to
her science work she is also deeply
interested in science policy and
evidence informed decision making so in
2018 um zivani co-founded the toronto
science policy network and among the
national campaigns she has co-led is the
report on the early impacts of quover 19
ungraduate students across canada
and we also have ukusana
she is in
a fourth year phd candidate in health
economics at u of t and upasana is also
a director of integrated health systems
and partnerships at humber river
hospital and she has led the rollout um
the rollout of vaccine clinics around
the city of toronto including helping
launch u of t st george campuses vaccine
clinic um let me uh
let me uh ask uh upasana first um
go ahead and sign if you have questions
and i invite the other junior fellows to
to um ask questions as as as follows
thanks vincent and thank you alan and
derek um one of the questions because
we've heard a lot about canada
addressing the manufacturing bottleneck
um and then also advancing about the
next applications of the modified mrna
what are one or two the really important
things that universities and
organizations like sci-fi can do right
now to be better better prepared for a
future circumstance for a pandemic if it
was to occur
well i'll jump in here there so i i
think the the job of universities and
you can see that in the vaccines that uh
we're all using now for coving uh is to
do the fundamental science
uh because that's what they really do
well so the you know the mrna technology
as derek said came out of the university
of pennsylvania uh uh garrick
polished it as it were at harvard and
then the company um
uh it's the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
and the viral vector technology was
actually developed at mcmaster
university way back by frank graham so i
think what universities can contribute
to this pipeline
is the fundamental research
and i think what what cfar does i think
really well is uh to do research you
need talent you need people like derek
um and and we're pretty good at
nurturing great talent and mentoring
great young people uh and so and and uh
so i think that's that's our role but
but uh
generally but i think the role of
universities it's critical um and it
doesn't stop by the way the to the
vaccines if you think about the pcr
reaction well that was developed at a
company to see this but but uh dna
sequencing was developed in an academic
environment by fred sanger at the sanger
center so at cambridge university so
those technologies which are so key to
dealing with this virus were all
developed if we trace them back
as academic environments i think that's
a big role critical role and only
universities can do that because if you
think about as derek said the companies
are now piling into rna vaccine
technology
but the big companies wouldn't have done
that five years ago
it was too risky too long term so only
universities can nurture that high risk
long-term research
uh that may or may not pay off in terms
of a product
uh
now universities are lousy in making
product in my judgment that's where
companies come in that's where biotech
companies come in that's where big
pharma comes in so there's a real
complementarity between the private
sector and the public sector in terms of
you know universities um and when it
works it works fantastically well as
we're seeing with the rna vaccines
and i i i would yeah i would agree
universities are the the largest and
most productive innovation ecosystems on
the planet and so
university leadership should continue to
foster just that so couldn't agree more
with what ellen said
stevonnie can you do
would you would you like to
follow up
yes i actually had a question regarding
how how what challenges did you face
moving from
studying mrna in a university setting
into
developing moderna and
moving that into an industrial
environment and what challenges maybe
that you were anticipating that work
didn't end up being challenges at all
so if you can speak a little bit about
well well i was a first-time
entrepreneur when i uh did uh founded
moderna and um i was lucky in that i did
my research in you know at uh at harvard
university and i was within the
ecosystem of uh cambridge uh boston
which is the largest ecosystem of
biotech on planet earth so i got lucky
that i i did my work in the center of
this biotech uh the the biotech
uh the
hub of the planet
uh so that allowed me actually
relatively easy access to
mentors that had done it before which is
really important as i said what first
investor was tim springer who had
founded millennium uh uh well um
leukocyte that was bought by millennium
pharmaceuticals he was in my department
i had many people in my department that
had founded companies so great mentors
uh and you know also within that
ecosystem there's uh
uh you know ip expertise
um
venture capital
big pharma is there so it really isn't
the ecosystem is totally set up there to
to and you know it's something that i
don't know how many what the number of
companies that come out of harvard and
mit each year is but it's astounding i
can tell you that so they've got it down
to an art there that's for sure and they
have it as such in other places of the
planet too and i talked to canadian
universities uh a lot about this i've
talked to u of t and and you alberta and
others
about what they need to do or what more
they could do and this ecosystem is
built over a long period of time but it
it you know and it usually needs you
know an
anchor sort of an early anchor company
history you know some company that
strikes it big and then builds that the
ecosystem builds from there you know for
example in south san francisco it was
genentech uh and
lo and behold you know 40 years after
the founding of genentech there's this
vibrant ecosystem all around the south
sanford actually to be honest it starts
with great academic institutions back to
this point that that allen made because
that's that's really the key it starts
from that but then you need an anchor
company and then all of these other
pieces so
um
did
uh did i what did what was i
anticipating and not anticipating
i actually didn't know and i used to i
ended up teaching a course to harvard
undergrads about sort of after i did
modern and a couple of other companies
about how to sort of translate one's
ideas into sort of out of the bench to
the bend side by the formation of
biotech and i always started the lecture
every year by uh telling my students
that when i first started on this
journey i knew less than a block of wood
knows about you know launching a biotech
company because until you've actually
had that experience and done did that
because it's totally different different
than uh you know academic science you
know we're great at science but we're
not so good at moving those ideas
towards patients which of course
involves you know raising money yeah we
raise money with grants but not not in
the same way that you raise money uh to
start and and contin can have your
biotech uh thrive
so there's lots to be learned
from the um from doing it but there's
also lots to be learned from mentors so
every young person i talk to and it's
all the time you know that's really the
key thing get somebody who's done it
first early that can give you advice to
help you
along the way
uh nick do you have a question for the
panel i do yeah thanks so much for the
great conversation so far um i have a
question just to follow up on something
you guys mentioned earlier you talked
about how
easy it is to modify mrna vaccines to
new variants which is great um but you
know at the population level as you
mentioned manufacturing and rolling out
vaccines can be quite a cumbersome task
uh if kovid continues to mutate um at
what point does it make sense to modify
the vaccines like is there a consensus
on when that might be give like a
personal opinion on the threshold of
effectiveness um yeah
yeah sure well
just to tell you that so so alan i'll
let you uh in in one sec just to say
that uh
beta uh beta and delta
var mrna variants already in phase two
at moderna so
uh when you and the reason beta and beta
emerged in south africa the reason that
it was chosen to go through and be a gen
2 vaccine if you were is because studies
had shown that gen 1 vaccine while
being protective still against beta were
not as good at neutralizing the antibody
or the uh viruses ability to infect
cells there was a market drop off uh in
protective ability so it made sense to
you know again the sequencing was done
we knew exactly where the mutations were
you can very easily tailor an mrna for
that and and that's as i said in phase
two similarly delta so i think that the
threshold really is when gen one or two
or three vaccines cease to become you
know protective you know really
protective and you see more and more
breakthrough infra infections and that's
measurable and we know who's been
vaccinated yet still ends up with covet
or ends up you know hopefully not in the
hospital or on ventilators or dying but
that happens at a certain uh frequency
as well so
uh this is the most studied medical
intervention uh in all of human history
that's for sure uh so uh essentially
every academic and you know pharma
research around the planet has got
doing something working on covit so this
is this is going to really
help in our response but but covet is
uh or source code 2 is def almost
certainly going to become endemic we're
going to see it you know every year kind
of like influenza i think it's mostly
epidemiologists agree it will continue
to mutate hopefully it doesn't become
much more
deadly
and if it becomes real deadly usually
they you know viruses burn themselves
out like the original sars or ebola or
something like this usually it's not
it's not really in the in the interests
of the uh
of the virus to get to become too deadly
and kill its host of course
um but we're gonna we're gonna be
dealing with it for a long time ellen
did you want to add something you know
well i would agree with what you said i
would just add quickly nicholas to
answer your question
two things one is i think that's where
the other technologies come in so if you
see from the epidemiology
that the incidence of culvert is
starting to go up
and couple that with sequencing and you
see that a new variant frequency is
starting to go up
uh even in people who have been
vaccinated you already have a clue
before you do any lab work
that the uh the vaccine is not working
against this new variant you can then
you know take serif in those individuals
and see their if their antibodies
actually neutralize the virus
to sort of confirm that
so
if you see that then you have to then go
from there so i think that's it's at
that point that you to go back to your
question which is a great question it's
the kind of question of the day really
it's at that point that you think we
need a new vaccine so um now in terms of
viral evolution
uh as as derek was saying you know
the selection pressure on the virus in
the first instance is to be more
transmissible
and the the delta is is about four to
six fold more transmissible than the
original virus
uh and obviously the more quickly you
can spread
without killing the host
the more selective advantage you have
now as more and more people get
vaccinated we may or may not see immune
escape variants that is variants that
are no longer
uh subject to the vaccine and the
antibodies or other immune system
responses that are elicited by those
vaccines
now if that happens then you know we've
got to make a new vaccine we haven't
seen that yet i mean there are some
vaccines some viruses sorry some
variants that are a little bit more
resistant to the to the vaccine than
than before but but nothing
striking
so it is possible
that the constraints on the virus
to mutate and still be viable are such
that it can't escape even the original
generation of vaccines that's a
possibility and i think the longer this
goes on and the more and more people get
vaccinated and the longer time goes
before we actually see a
an escape variant the more confident
we'll be able to feel g this this bar
can't escape this vaccine
no
that's that's a hope that's my fingers
are crossed okay so we'll see what
happens um but i think we can
kind of rest assured and maybe uh it's
too confident that because of the plug
and play and how quickly we can develop
these vaccines
we can re-engineer them
uh to do to do to deal with any new
variant of concern that comes up
well
exactly right and i would just add that
it really shows you know how
you know thank you virologists for
teaching us about how coronaviruses get
into cells because basically the spike
protein is that that uh protein that
engages the ac2 receptor to initiate the
infectious cycle uh and its interaction
with the ac2 receptor on human cells
it's a structural interaction so you're
not going to be able to mutate that
spike protein so much and still imagine
that it that engages with the human cell
so the target is exactly right to block
the initiation of the infectious cycle i
think where we might have to worry about
a little bit is when other genes with it
and of course the whole genome is
mutating of uh the coronavirus when
other genes mutate to um
you know uh propagate
uh viral replication and hopefully not
uh lethality that don't act through the
spike protein because the spike protein
clearly is the right target and we've
targeted very effectively with current
vaccines
uh and there's a selective pressure to
have that
that interaction between the spike
protein and the ace2 receptor remain
intact so
i agree with that think about a lock and
a key
necklace that you know the the h2
receptor is the lock and the spike
protein is the key the lock isn't
changing we don't mutate uh so if you
imitate the key too much it doesn't work
anymore in that lock exactly
right so but if the other proteins in
the virus start to mutate then we have
to rely on drugs probably
and there are some drugs now being
developed they're therapeutic they're
not they're not they're not preventable
they're therapeutic but i see natalie's
back on the screen so that's
that that's a sign that uh that we're
going to have to lock and key this this
discussion uh in in some fashion
i mean what a fabulous discussion how
much we've learned and i know i think it
demonstrates the value of the c4 talks
the massey see far talks because we
wanted to continue to talk to you and
listen to you i mean this demonstrate
the power science the power of
interdisciplinarity
all of you have spoken to uh the big
challenges for all disciplines uh
including laws uh in terms of
moving to a better future future where
we're all healthier and are able to
resist uh the future pandemics so
uncolleen foie thank you so much uh all
of you thank you to the junior fellows
thank you to wincy uh for leading the
discussion and thank you to our both of
our panelists uh alan bernstein and
thank you very much derek for making
yourself available for this this talk uh
you have a standing
invitation to come to massey college any
time
thank you
thank you all
[Music]